see that due to your local anarchist
meeting that weird guy at the mosque
well he might be an informant part of
the big bad surveillance machine is a
big network of informants and they're
charged with one simple task get
information on groups and people that
the government doesn't really trust and
since 9/11 the American informant
network has grown into its own industry
in 1975 there were 1500 paid FBI
informants and in 1980 2,800 but in 2011
over 15,000 informants often also target
in minority communities especially the
Muslims almost half of terrorism related
prosecution's between 2001 and 2011
involve the use of a paid informant and
informants also often have a criminal
past which is actually used to give them
the choice between either going to
prison or while becoming an informant
and the right choice can pay informants
can make up to one hundred thousand
dollars for providing good information
how's that for the informant industry